but right now let's talk about the
tragic death on The Bachelorette Nancy I
know you were watching last I was I
admit I'm a fan of the show but in case
you were not watching here's what
happened one of the bachelors Eric
killed died in a paragliding accident
shortly after he was eliminated from the
show so last night to show remembered
him the question is how well did they
handle this very delicate situation
we're talking to Eric's brother as we
analyze the Bachelorette tribute was it
sensational or was it sensitive I know
this is difficult even awkward to be
here tonight but I really appreciate it
yeah it's devastating you know to even
talk about it I don't envy the situation
that ABC was in giving us given the
circumstances in lieu of a rose ceremony
viewers watched a six-minute somewhat
awkward Q&A between Chris and Andy about
Eric's memory and last dramatic moments
on the show I came on this to meet a
person not a TV actor getting on my TV
actors eating I'm doing a poker face
right now yeah for you to sit here and
tell me that I have a poker face it's so
offensive would you have changed
anything would you have handled it
differently it's not ideally the last
conversation that I would want to have
with somebody Eric's older brother Scott
watched the final episode and spoke to
us this morning from the family's
hometown of Salt Lake City it's kind of
a fine balance I think for anybody to
deal with a situation like this I
thought they they did a fine job love to
have the opportunity to sit down with
with Andy and in person and kind of get
her perspective off camera
overnight Bachelorette tweets have
erupted to over 76,000 and Counting
so we asked you on our Facebook page if
the tribute was appropriate or not and
68% agree with ABC but many Bachelorette
bloggers were not impressed sadly this
episode was more about and even Eric
what kind of tribute is that this
morning we called up Chris Harrison to
get his take after Eric said goodbye it
felt Hollow and a little callous and
disrespectful and it just it just didn't
feel right and so we went back and tried
to figure out what did feel appropriate
and it was to cut that out and to insert
this interview which we did just a few
weeks ago - talking about Eric people
also need to understand that this hasn't
happened in the life of the show yet he
just left last night but obviously he
has not passed away and so we're still
we're still actually going to have to
deal with his death and how it actually
affected everybody on the show well to
pay tribute to Eric after his tragic
passing his family started to live like
Eric foundation to cherish his memory as
a global Trailblazer it's an opportunity
to carry on his legacy through some
through some projects kind of redefining
extreme philanthropy
beautiful idea well here's my taking the
whole thing you know I'm glad that they
got rid of the rose ceremony last night
it would have been inappropriate felt
inappropriate it's a tough situation
that ABC was in however I wanted to hear
more from his family not as much from
Andy and you just heard Eric's brother
tell us they set up a philanthropic
foundation in Eric's honor and I think
that was a missed opportunity for the
show they could have brought some great
awareness to the foundation it's
definitely a difficult delicate and a
television segment
[Music]